for many a tradition on christmas eve
involves
eating chinese food while tonight is a
big night for restaurants that serve
asian cuisine
it's no doubt it's been a tough year for
all restaurants
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough is live at archie's thai
bistro with how they're doing right now
madison
yes bianca concerns over covet 19
impacted several asian restaurants
across the valley
at the start of the pandemic but we are
happy to report that isn't the case
anymore
back in march there with the
with the onset of the pandemic there
definitely was a lot of fear and
uncertainty
barely understanding the new virus back
in the spring the las vegas asian
chamber of commerce estimated that
business for most asian restaurants was
down between
40 and 60 percent that decline was way
more significant than other non-asian
restaurants
we had one older lady for example who
was just trying to help somebody with
their groceries and
she got yelled at and said hey don't
touch my groceries i don't want your
germs
now with it being the end of the year
several asian restaurants like archie's
thai bistro say they are not
experiencing that type of behavior
anymore from the public
and that they will make their quota for
the end of the year of course
it's not the same as before especially
that this time is probably one of the
busiest time of the year
but they have to deal with you know with
a limited capacity at the moment
the good thing is the optimism we still
see a lot of patronage now compared to
before which is great uh the restaurants
are breaking even
and ronacon believes his three
restaurants will end the year in a good
place
not having to deal with racial bias
however acknowledges the fact that we
are still in a pandemic
so the decrease in customers is still
prevalent usually this is the busiest
time of the year but
this is also a very different year so
we'll see what happens
and you know we've seen a constant flow
of people come in to the restaurant
and the food looks amazing so i am
actually going to go get some to-go food
let me know if you want me to bring any
back to the station
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now